[Music]
we met Ally Brooke is 1/5 1/5 harmony
one of the most successful girl groups
of all time I want to be on that stage
and entertain I'm an entertainer 3
albums three world tours and the only
girl group that has two music videos
with more than a billion views each now
Ali is breaking through as a solo artist
and be who I it's a topic that got her a
bit choked up when we met at a Burbank
recording studio for our sit down
interview over to you ready this is my
life as a Latina I want to take it back
to the beginning you're a young girl
growing up in San Antonio Texas
what was your first memory of mom and
dad I think I want to be a singer I
started singing around the house when I
was just you know a little baby kind of
just being in the backseat like three
years old just singing like gospel songs
and just kind of constantly singing
around one day my third grade teacher
she approached my parents and she said
hey I overheard your daughter she was
singing and I think she's really
talented you should do something about
that at the age of nine I think my
parents put me into an awesome
organization in San Antonio called Naya
which is Network for young artists it's
a program that puts kids and different
shows around town
[Music]
I remember just totally falling in love
with it and being like this is magic to
me I didn't really know how to put into
words all I knew was that it just felt
like nothing had ever made me feel
before her baby she came out screaming
and the doctor told us it's weird that
she's screaming
she shouldn't be yelling at a pound 14
ounces and you know fast forward and now
she's 25 years old and she's this
amazing artists vocalist I'm like by the
time Ali was 12 she was home-schooled
flying back and forth from San Antonio
to Los Angeles trying to launch her
career when you're young and you know
you want to be in the arts it's crucial
to have that support from your parents
talk to me about what their involvement
meant to you as a child as you were
trying to pursue your dreams they
seriously like I don't even know how to
put into words how thankful I am for
them and they gave me that confidence
and they sacrificed so much for me and
supported me along the way even when it
was so hard and even when when I was
younger you know and going through
things when I didn't believe in myself
then I felt like I wasn't good enough
and they were just right there to to
encourage me and to support me and to
say that you know I believe in you
and that is some is priceless there are
no words to say I think plan to have
them in my life you mentioned that your
parents made several sacrifices in order
for you to pursue your dreams what were
some of those things that they had to do
my mom actually was born with scoliosis
and her back
so bad I mean her condition just
completely deteriorated she is
superwoman to me she is Wonder Woman to
me I don't know how first of all she
could even walk and get out of bed every
day but did betray yeah physically but
to travel and to be in a whole different
city of that sacrifice of literally
putting her health on the line on the
line for me was just remarkable I
remember being like in an apartment with
like like silverfish would be in it but
we'd have to make do with what we had
and they were still there to drive me to
the studio and to drive me to Marshall's
to get clothes like to dress me up we
may not have had much but night was
there she was there and my parents would
find a way and my dad he made sacrifices
too with his work it would be a little
risky to say I need to please let me
work that work from home nope I didn't
let me work from home because I needed
to go out with my daughter in LA to help
her out my parents were there and they
they believed and they were rooting me
on and we did it together
I do this for them like I want to buy my
mom and dad become one day go yeah
that's a goal and I want to write a song
for them I want to be able to bless them
in a way that can do a little bit of
what they did for me
[Music]
[Applause]
what does being Latino mean to you being
latina means being strong and courageous
and I think the number one thing is
passionate we want people to come into
our homes and feel like it's it's their
home we have such beautiful culture with
our music with our dancing with our food
I am so thankful that I am latina Kym's
when I'm with you I want to know making
this video do you remember making this
video I do look at me trying to play my
good time not even playing it right oh
my god well they're mine today at 25
when you watch Sally here I can't
believe it for that girl who was in her
bedroom making songs and trying to make
something happen so so so much do you
think this girl in her bedroom ever
thought she'd be in one of the most
successful groups of all time look I
told that girl she would not believe
[Music]
in 2012 then eighteen-year-old Ali took
a chance in audition for The X Factor
[Music]
it didn't work out for Ali as a soloist
but the judges gave her another shot
this time in a group are you gonna stand
over there with the girls you are all
look at that as you are invited to the
judges paper they went on to become
fifth harmony
looking back on the x-factor would you
say that was a positive experience the
x-factor was a positive experience to an
extent but I learned a lot Ally got
candid about navigating the highs and
lows being a group was incredible but so
many opinions happened and like so much
judgment who was it coming from feel
like everybody I kind of let the
opinions overtake me and I kind of felt
like I needed to step back and like
really be mindful of who I was and what
I did and even songwriting like it was
hard to really do that in a group
because there's so many opinions for a
little bit you kind of think I'm not
like good enough that people put you in
a box and everybody had their own like
role but I didn't want to fit a role
like I wanted to just be myself so that
was just sad
I just really heartbroken you know I
mean I know probably everyone felt that
way in a way for sure but like you know
everyone has their own experience but I
just felt like it's the worst when you
feel like you can't be yourself you're
not even seen for yourself
fifth harmony announced an indefinite
hiatus in March
is there any chance is there any
conversation about revisiting the group
and making music together again possibly
in the future you know what you never
know what can happen yeah you're living
the door open I would say leave we're
all probably leaving the door open okay
which means it's time for Ally to get
back to her original plan as a solo
artist
[Music]
congratulations you're officially
assigned solo artists thank you Oh how
does that feel to even like hear that
out loud
dang it's incredible everything I went
through all the ups and downs I'm a
signed artist I feel like I'm living a
new life now is this the rebirth of
alley Brook yes I would definitely say
it's the rebirth of alley broke Who I am
someone to you who looks a little hotter
someone there who ain't afraid to take
it farther
I'm truly back to who who I was I just
kind of imagine me now and then that
twelve year old me
kind of like meeting and like we're
hugging and embracing and I guess I
found you
what are you discovering about yourself
when it comes to music right about what
I want to write about sing it what I
want to sing about I'm also like doing
things that kind of surprised me too
vocally and pushing myself you know even
fashion is so important to me you've
been expressing myself in you know
wearing what I want to wear and there's
no one telling you what you can or can't
do anyway yeah yeah they're your own
boss yeah it's a beautiful journey
oh I wanna stay I wanna do
[Music]
Alley is still in the early stages of
recording her debut album I can't
but she's hard at work with lots of
industry heavyweights it's definitely
still in the pop realm for sure
signatures different different like
styles of pop but at all is cohesive my
heart is pumping
what are you writing music about are you
in love everything love and deeper
emotions and writing about family and
having a good time and owning who you
are in your womanhood and being strong
in what you want there's so much it's
going on in my music right now thank you
I can't wait
here we go three of my biggest career
goals would have to be I would love to
do a world tour one day to be nominated
for Grammy and I'd love to act in a film
for your biggest influences it's making
this record oh my gosh well first and
foremost always is selena quintanilla
[Music]
she's my number one like she is my angel
her spirit truly shined through her
wrecker it's an on that stage and she is
always my inspiration for her life
another one of course is you know
growing up Jennifer Lopez when she paved
the way for so many yeah Latinas
like Selena and JLo Ali is now carrying
the torch is one of the most influential
young latinas in music I feel like such
a such a lucky girl gonna work really
hard now I want to be known close friend
and someone who deeply truly cares about
other people someone who was brave and
went for a dream and hopefully and
hopefully an inspiration
[Music]